the holy roman empire was a staple of
european politics throughout the
entirety of the middle ages
its emperors held positions of immense
influence which they maintained until
1806 when napoleon happened
yet given the importance of the holy
roman empire historically why was it
dissolved why did the holy roman empire
come to an end and why did nobody do
anything about it
so by 1806 europe had been plagued by
near constant war with france for over a
decade and napoleon now the emperor of
france had plans to reforge europe in
france's image and interests
strangely enough many of europe's rulers
opposed this and so were currently
fighting a war against france as a
coalition to crush napoleon once and for
all but fun fact
no napoleon and his generals had
routinely defeated the coalition allies
and in 1805 they thoroughly crushed the
austrians at the battle of austerlitz
soon after this austria made peace with
france and napoleon was essentially
given free reign to rearrange central
europe how he pleased
this led him creating the confederation
of the rhine the next year which was a
collective of german states who in
return for some territorial
consolidation were to be french puppets
and fight when napoleon asked
furthermore napoleon granted himself the
title of protector of the confederation
of the rhine
and to many this second power structure
within the holy roman empire was
essentially its practical end since
their allegiance was now to paris and
not vienna
the current holy roman emperor francis
ii believed that napoleon was coming for
his title
as such francis did the only thing that
he could he announced his abdication and
as his last act he dissolved the holy
roman empire
whilst he absolutely had the right to do
the abdicating bit it was less clear
whether or not he had the authority to
abolish the empire as a whole
despite the fact it was a gray area and
the empire did
so why did everyone just go along with
it the reason why other german states
and rulers were fine with it was that
the title of holy roman emperor was by
this point ceremonial
the holy roman emperor couldn't levy
armies prevent his subjects from making
foreign alliances or even stop a certain
naughtier subject from warring against
the emperor himself if they wanted to
the fact was that the existence of the
holy roman empire was by and large
irrelevant to the everyday running of
its constituent states
and for the remaining german rulers in
the confederation of the rind the new
system had just allowed them to swallow
up some of their smaller neighbors with
no problems
so for them it was definitely a win even
if napoleon had more oversight than the
emperor did so what about napoleon the
only man who could have if he wished
simply declared the empire to still
exist
well whilst he could have taken the
title for himself he had no reason to
the confederation of the rhyme was
largely a buffer state against
austria prussia and russia whereas
maintaining the holy roman empire
wouldn't have provided the same security
because prussia in austria could
potentially tip the internal balance of
power
he also had no reason to oppose its
abolition in the end of the empire his
new europe didn't need what many
saw as a bloated inefficient relic of
the medieval era and
importantly without a holy roman emperor
who also helped the title of king in
germany there was no central figure that
the german states could rally around and
oppose him
now they had to side with either himself
the king of prussia or the emperor of
austria
and of those last two those in the
confederation of the rhine had no reason
to side with austria whereas many of
them had much to fear from prussia
and so the holy roman empire died not
with any fanfare or conflict but simply
because nobody cared enough to save it
the last emperor declared his title
abolished and ultimately nobody else
wanted it
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker marvin
castle mo aaron the white
james castaneda marcus arsenal jordan
longley gustav swann rasheed ali
jerry lambda maggie patzkowski
coppertone winston cayward spencer
lightfoot robert wetzel spinning three
plates corso wolff matthew shipley
anthony beckett and charles the first
you